hello everyone and welcome to another
really wild game from the 2020 chasuble
masters I didn't think I'd be recording
any more videos today but then this game
happened and of course I have to do it
so I hope you hope you guys don't mind
now it's the new Lupo vs. Magnus Carlsen
from and this is their second game from
this tournament
dubov defeated Magnus with the black
pieces in the first part of the
tournament and now we have the second
game between the two of them and it's
it's quite the game so without further
ado let's check it out
dubov opens with d4 we have Knight to f6
by Magnus Knight to f3 d5 and the c4 of
course and east 6 sorry about that
sorry not eastex we don't have the
Queens gambit declined or or anything
like that we have c6 my bad
nice to see 3 and now east 6 if we go
into the semi Slav we have g3 du Bois
prepares to fianchetto his LightSquared
Bishop and Knight B to d7 with Bishop to
g2 and the Magnus prepares the castle
Bishop to e7 and both players Castle we
have castles castles and b3 double now
is ready to fianchetto his dark square
Bishop as well so the two bishops will
be or should be very strong and b6
Magnus wants to develop his light square
bishop via this diagonal as its well
it's it's gonna be a bit hard developing
it this way so rook to e1 and now Bishop
to a6 putting pressure on the c4 pawn
and now do both defense defensive good
night to d2 defense this and maybe in
the future that the two knights can give
support to him to move like efore so
look the c8 Carlsen continuous
development and Bishop to b2 just nicely
developing and there is one game in the
database where Bishop b7 was played and
it's important to mention that it was a
game between two 1800 elo players so
yeah and it's from 2007 so those guys
were really onto something playing such
such you know deep engine preparation
game in those days but yeah here a
Magnus goes for c5 instead and it is as
a move 11 that we have a completely new
game so he strikes in the center right
away gets rid of his well sort of a week
c6 pawn
and dubov trades with D captors and c5
Knight captures and now B for kicking
the night away Knight to e4 here do both
trades once a Knight captures we have D
captures Magnus here doubles up his a
pawn but it's not not that big of a deal
since this not a knight is stuck for the
moment guarding the the c4 pawn since
the bishop is attacking it and also this
bishop is attacking the be four points
odubel needs to do something about that
he goes for b5 he pushes the bishop back
so bishop the b7 now the b4 is no longer
a target and now III I just nicely
develops his pawn to e3 and Bishop to b4
by Magnus just pinning the knight so now
the knight cannot move as the rook will
be under attack the book immediately on
pins rook to e2 and now Queen to d3 and
I stifling move that doesn't allow dubov
all that many moves the the knife is
still stuck regarding the c4 pawn the
Queen is stopped guarding the rook here
so not not a lot you can do here duo
goes for the probably the best idea here
look to be one with the threat of just
Bishop captures night and then opening
up a discovery here on the bishop so
Magnus offers a trade here with Bishop
to c3 and now what you probably want to
do here is capture this and after lights
a character's captors go rook c1 and why
should have a very nice game let's say
Queen back to a 3 or 2 d 3 and now it's
still continues our point is that you
still cannot move the Queen since the
rook hangs and the ones this row gets
developed here black will again have a
very very pleasant game so instead of
Bishop to c3 with captures dubov goes
for Bishop to a 3 and this is where the
game really starts to get fun so here
look F to d8 by Magnus now the problem
is there's a triple attack on the knight
here now you could defend it with
something like Bishop to b4 add another
defender here this leaves the c4 pawn
vulnerable to rook captures and c4 and
now you cannot capture because of just
Queen characters on d1 so that's the
problem so here after rook F to d8 do
both defended with rook to b3 now the
bishop is pinned you cannot move it but
now there's a different idea here so
feel free to pause the video here and
try to find the best move for black
while I give you a couple of seconds so
for those of you who were able to do it
congratulations on offering a very very
unpleasant Queen trade for white and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show its Queen captures on c4 and now
accepting this trade is a much easier
said than done for example if you
capture now let's say Knight captures on
c4 then comes rook captures on d1 with
the check you have to block it you
cannot block with the with the rook so
you have to block with the bishop and
now Bishop to d5 and here why this
without a move there the knight is
threatened and it's not all that easy to
move it wherever you move it the bishop
can capture it and then you just play
Bishop c4 and there is nothing to be
done here for white so you'd have to go
for some like captures but again after
Bishop captures on c4 it's all over but
the line goes a bit deeper and it's
super fun so I'm just gonna show it here
white what can go for this rook the seat
you move and now of course you cannot
capture with the bishop because you'll
get checkmated well you won't get
checkmated the bishop can retreat but
you will survive the attack after real
character sense e8 so here black would
have to go for captures with the check
King g2 and now Knight the g4 puts
pressure on f2 and now the point is
after rook captures on c4 you have this
nice in-between move rook captures on f2
with check and after rook captures now
Knight captures an e3 checks the king
and forks the rook so after the King
moves you're just gonna gobble up the
rook now with the night or the rogue
doesn't really matter and here okay I
vote let's have a look and a minor piece
however Magnus would be up three pawns
which is of course completely winning so
this is what happens if you accept the
Queen trade so dubov declines the trade
he goes for Quinta he one gets the Queen
away from the D file but the Queen isn't
all that much happier here since the the
night is still pinned you still can't
move the knight so here Magnus goes back
Queen d5 introduces again a third
attacker to the night here
and here we have finally Bishop to b4 by
do both this is the strongest defensive
move by the engine and it's still not
enough so once again pause the video
here and try to find the absolute best
winning move for black well I'll give
you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on offering your
queen year again and for those of you
who just want to enjoy the show its
Queen captures and b3 now and now again
there are so many options here for white
but black just grab your look so you
have to decide what you do here problem
is if you just trade Queens with night
captures then you've just given up the
exchange Bishop captures rook captures
and once the Brooks go down the board
you know to become pigs and to gobble
everything up
there's just no no counter play here for
white you're the ear down the exchange
your position is worse and there's not
much to be not much to look for here so
instead after this Queen captures on b3
by Magnus odubel accepts the Queen
sacrifice and he goes for a captures and
b3 but now we have Bishop captures on b4
as now you can capture it and there's
still an attack on the night here so
here do go play Bishop to f1 and there
really aren't all that many moves you
can play here so Bishop to f1 was played
but now comes a five by Magnus and it's
a good idea since do both kind of could
have gone for a queen to a one he could
have given up the night for maybe some
Queen captures on a seven counter play
but it still wouldn't be enough here
Magnus goes for a5 and you cannot
capture it if you capture up a song then
just Bishop captures and there's well
not much you can do here the rook is
stuck there just gonna grab a lot more
material you're gonna eliminate this guy
then you've removed the defender of the
night you're gonna get rid of the knight
as well everything falls apart so here
duo played Queen to d1 again there's
nothing you can play here and you still
cannot move the the rook problem is
booboo is also very long time cousin has
some almost five minutes and dubov is
around thirty seconds on the clock so
it's not easy to make a move
because you're long time but also there
is no move to be made and here to finish
the game nicely Magnus just played h6 we
reached the position from the thumbnail
and it was also in this position that
Daniel to resign the game as there is
nothing more to be done here so there is
no move for white to be played like you
could waste some moves with the pawns
but at some point the position
the position will block itself so now
you don't really gain anything by
pushing the pawns without you know
making any sense
and everything else just loses like if
you try queenie one unpinning you still
haven't done pinned because the knight
is under attack still just Roxie - you
add a third attacker and you're just
gonna pick up the night and win the game
easily on the other hand after h6 you
could try something like let's say rook
to e1 but the again doesn't help you
you're just gonna lose the night here so
you could try something like a bishop to
g22 to keep the tension and everything
going on but white is still without a
move just work the seven you're gonna
double up here and you're gonna win the
knight again there is no move to be
played Bishop f1 rook here and you're
just gonna win the game easily and for
those of you who are maybe new to the
channel or new to chess in general if
you're thinking about okay but I still
have a queen why not just give up the
night let's play something like just
move the Queen let's say to be one and
we give up the night the problem is
after let's say the knight is captured
and you play something let's say Bishop
back to c3 yes you still have a queen
but black has well a bishop and Knight
and a rook for your queen and usually
sometimes even two pieces are too much
for the Queen to handle if the position
is right three pieces for the Queen
three pieces are basically always ago
but two P two minor pieces and the rook
that's just overwhelming for the Queen
so that of course both do do go and the
magnets know that this is unplayable for
white so now after this Queen d1 and
it's very interesting you could have
played like any move here and your
position is still overwhelming and
winning but this is this h6 really a
poetic way to end the game and dubov
agrees he doesn't want to over drag it
and he allows the game to finish in 25
moves so now a very exciting stuff I do
hope you guys enjoyed it I always enjoy
winders like a tube swung happening like
I moved 2025 with a lot of pieces on the
board with at least one Queen still on
the board so it was a well I I enjoyed
it very much
I do hope you enjoyed it as well so I
would like to thank Robert Thermal Alex
wolf berry bloom at Thomas
Dube and Andrew Berman for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot - really appreciate it as usual you
can check - in my previous videos Aaron
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon continuing the coverage of the
chasuble masters 20/20 checking up on
your wonderful suggestions and whatever
else happens in the chess world so thank
you all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your Monday